I've opened up about certain experiences
that at the time were absolutely
terrifying anything that takes your mind
into a different place that ultimately
you learn something from fits within the
genre of exploration of Altered States
of consciousness
today we talk about Consciousness time
travel String Theory quantum gravity and
wormholes Brian Greene is a theoretical
physicist a mathematician and a string
theorist who is best known for his work
on mirror symmetry and flop transitions
Brian's also a professor at Columbia
University as well as the chairman of
the world Science Festival and the
author of several popular books on
physics including the elegant Universe
this was a purposefully desultory
interview which brought us both to
uncomfortable ground comfortably you'll
see what I mean my name's Kurt J Mongol
I have a background in mathematical
physics this podcast is called theories
of everything is dedicated to the
exploration of theories of everything
from a theoretical physics perspective
but as well as exploring the role
Consciousness has to the fundamental
laws of nature each sponsor as well as
the patrons improves the quality of the
videos drastically it improves the depth
it improves the frequency and it goes
toward paying the staff for instance
someone who's editing this full time
right now and then we have an operations
manager in that vein I want to thank
today's sponsor brilliant if you're
familiar with toe you're familiar with
brilliant but for those who don't know
Brilliance is a place where you go to
learn math science and engineering
through these bite-sized Interactive
Learning experiences for example and I
keep saying this I would like to do a
podcast on information Theory
particularly Chiara marletto which is
David Deutsch's student has a theory of
everything that she puts forward called
Constructor Theory which is heavily
contingent on information Theory so I
took their course on random variable
distributions and knowledge and
uncertainty in order to learn a bit more
about entropy now there's this formula
for entropy essentially hammered into
you as an undergraduate which seems to
have fallen from the sky however when
you take Brilliance course it was the
first time that I could see that it's an
extremely clear and intuitive formula
that is to say that it would be
unnatural to Define it in any other
manner visit brilliant.org toe that is
t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription and I recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons I think
you'll be greatly surprised that the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects you previously had a difficult
time grocking at some point I'll also go
through the courses and give a
recommendation in order if you'd like to
support the theories of everything
podcast and help assist that is the
improved video quality the depth the
frequency of the podcast and paying the
staff then do consider going to
patreon.com
kurtjimungle the link is on screen as
well as in the description there's a
custom amount as well as already
delineated tiers either way your
viewership is thank you enough enjoy
this episode with Brian Greene
Professor Brian Greene it's an honor to
speak with you I've been researching you
since I was young and also as I've
gotten older it's an honor thank you for
coming on thank you appreciate that
thank you so much
what have you been working on in the
past year and what do you hope to
accomplish in the next year and this
year
well uh yeah I've been working on some
strange things of late which I'm almost
afraid to talk about but since they've
been published I I guess I shouldn't at
all hold back
but it sounds a little kooky
uh it sounds like the kind of things
that I receive in you know emails and
crank letters for the past 30 years it
it has to do with questioning whether
the speed of light really is the limit
for Signal transmission
and we all know that as anyone who's
taken basic physics studied special
relativity that it's an absolutely well
established fact that locally
the speed of light is the limit for
Signal transmission obviously going back
to Einstein and a gazillion experiment
since but there are some unusual
contexts that theories like string
theory suggest
and those contacts suggest that the
overall shape of space might be
non-trivial in the sense that it might
not just sort of go on forever space my
curve back on itself and you can ask
yourself what if the universe is in the
shape of a loop or at least there are
dimensions that are looped that as you
go out in One Direction you go far
enough you'll come back to your starting
point
and so we began to study signal
Transmission in universes where the
signal could go all the way around the
universe and root to its destination
and we found in certain circumstances
that I'd be happy to
elaborate that you could have signals
going in that unusual trajectory that
would get to their destination faster
than the signal that would seemingly be
the quicker one moving
right through the space-time without
traversing these these closed curves and
so we found that there are signals that
can go from here to there faster than
the speed of light this is related to
the topology of the universe and not the
variable speed of light yeah this is not
a variable speed of light
type of contribution as you know as
you're making a reference to there's
been a whole
industry that
for various physicists pursued over the
course of many years wondering about
whether the speed of light might vary
through time at temporal dependence to
the speed of light very interesting idea
I really don't know that there's much
evidence for it nor is there much
evidence for what I'm talking about
either so this is like throwing stones
in a glass house but be that as it may
you're right it all has to do with the
topology of space and if that topology
is non-trivial if they're
non-contractable Loops in that space
then that allows for qualitatively
different trajectories for signals
and when you take those into account you
find that the signals can have a net
speed that's faster than the speed of
light and moreover
it starts to sound a little bit kooky
but when you take special relativity you
learn that if signal can go faster in
the speed of light then there are
observers according to whom that signal
may arrive at its destination prior to
the time at which was emitted
and indeed we find examples of that in
other words we find examples where you
can send a signal into the past
and again I hesitate saying this but you
asked me the question of what I've been
working on lately so I feel I need to
answer fully and truthfully
um I hesitate to say this because this
has sort of been the playground
of kind of
thinkers who wanted to upset Einstein
and become the new Einstein to try to
find some flawout in the special
activity this is not a flaw from the
special relativity it's a feature of the
special relativity when applied to a
universe that has one of these
non-trivial topologies
so a close timeline curve doesn't go
against general relativity girdle had a
solution that has close timeline curves
are you suggesting some amendment to a
general relativity or are you just
saying look the actual structure of
space time or the shape of it is
different so you're not proposing new
laws no no laws yeah and so you know the
whole notion of closed time like curves
is a tricky one that's that's one where
there's a full trajectory that gets back
to its starting point prior to when it
departed and we don't exactly find those
kind of structures in these theories so
if I send a signal out into space and
send it somehow into the past and then
someone in the past gets that signal and
fires back toward me the return signal
will always get to me in at least no
time in other words it won't be that I
get the signal prior to I the moment
when I admitted it
so this would allow for interesting
things such as you know we've always
worried well worry it's probably too
strong a word we've always noted that if
we discover intelligent life out there
in the cosmos and it's very far away
how are we going to have a conversation
right we send out a signal hey how you
guys doing and what do we do we wait
like a hundred thousand years or a
million years for the return signal and
by that point we've forgotten that we're
in a conversation at all but in the
theories that I'm describing now with
these universes with these non-trivial
topologies you can send a signal out
into space and the person can get it and
respond and you will receive it in in
virtually no time in as little time as
as one can imagine and so you can have a
real-time conversation
with someone who's in an arbitrary
distance so I think that's pretty
startling and mind-boggling and kind of
wonderful and who knows if any of these
ideas happen to be true it would allow
for conversations that in the more usual
setting would just be impossible but no
it's no amendment to general relativity
it's no change at all to the fundamental
laws that's the kind of fun thing about
this approach you know if you come along
and say well let's now bend the laws of
physics as we knew it in the past change
it in some way sure obviously you're
going to get some new effects but then
it all depends on the utility of it
depends on was that amendment was that
changed at all reasonable so we're not
changing the laws of physics at all
we're just considering
shapes of space that are very natural in
certain unified theories like string
theory you know collusa Klein type
theories that people study in the past
and just examining conventional physics
in a new setting as opposed to new
physics in either conventional or new
setting is any of this related to
wormholes or is this separate
it is definitely separate
from wormholes in
the conventional way that people think
about wormholes but there is
um a deep Association in the following
sense
if you are looking at a signal that's
traversing say you know a circular
dimension of space
one of the most profitable ways
scientifically of studying that is to
imagine cutting that Circle and opening
it up into a line saying infinite line
and then just having global
identifications point zero identified
with two pi r identified with four Pi
with 6 pi r and so forth and in that way
you effectively have a circle because of
those identifications but you've
unraveled it into a more conventional
shape a line and then when a signal goes
from zero say to two pi r which really
in some sense happening is the signal is
then in essence jumping through a
wormhole and going back to its starting
point
and so you can reframe everything that
I'm talking about using the language of
wormholes but wormholes are not as
essential to the story as it might be in
certain other applications where you
start to worry about things like well is
it Wormhole traversable will it stay
open long enough for someone to actually
go through for a signal to go through in
this case a wormhole is really more of a
technique a mathematical technique for
analyzing the situation as opposed to
being fundamental to the whole idea
so this year your plans are what to work
on this Theory some more or
yeah that we're gonna definitely present
you know
look and what is this called by the way
sorry is there a name for this
or a paper that people can look up yeah
if you're written a couple of papers on
it the the most recent one has the title
Back to the Future
which um
the editors at physical review D
initially sent the paper back and said
we like the paper but you got to change
the title because it's like we just
don't have titles like that and I have
to say I kind of took a little bit
offenses too strong a word but you know
we wrote back to them and said sure
there's a cultural reference it's kind
of fun but it's not just the cultural
reference for a cultural reference's
sake we truly are talking about a signal
that can travel from us
back to the past and then into the
future because as I said before the
return signal always gets to us in a
non-negative amount of time so it's it's
Back to the Future it's like a perfect
description of what we're talking about
and to their credit the editors at
physical review D finally said yeah okay
you're right it works so the paper was
accepted with that somewhat perhaps
loose sounding title but one that really
does have a descriptive
approach to what we're talking about
that's spot on and so yeah if people
want to see the technical details that
would be a paper to look at
and you have an event coming up at least
here in Toronto on January 26th if I'm
not mistaken so that's about a week from
now when this is being published when
you're seeing this can you tell myself a
little bit about that in the audience as
well
yeah absolutely so the uh it's a talk at
Roy Thompson Hall I've never been there
before but at least the pictures look
like it's a quite beautiful venue and
it's a a journey that I'm going to take
the audience on from the beginning of
time up to the present and out toward
the farthest that science can take us
toward the end toward eternity
and my point in taking the audience on
this journey will be partly to
illuminate some of the key scientific
ideas that that guide the cosmological
unfolding on the largest of scales and
the largest of time scales
but I also want to give people a sense
of what science says about how we fit in
to this Cosmic order from this broadest
this largest perspective and so we will
be covering the formation of stars and
galaxies a little discussion about how
entropy and life interplay and play off
of one another and then once we get to
the present we'll turn our attention
toward the future and see how it all
comes crashing down when you look at
sufficiently large time scales as
entropy gains the upper hand
and I'll conclude the evening with some
remarks on how one might interpret this
large-scale understanding of the cosmos
in more human terms and how it is that
perhaps this perspective Can Shed light
on the age-old questions of of meaning
and purpose which occupy all of us in
one way or another so how does it shed
light on those on meaning and purpose
well objectively
so well you should come to the uh the
evening but I'm more than happy to
discuss it now in in Broad Strokes so
look you said objectively and I would
say I I don't know that objectively
there is an answer I think it is
ultimately the subject of search that
each human being is ultimately on to try
to make sense of their life make sense
of their existence but what this
perspective does for me and I found that
it resonates with many people
it it shows us how unbelievably
astoundingly unlikely our own existence
is
against the spectrum of possible
combinations of base pairs of DNA
against the spectrum of possible
molecular configurations against the
spectrum of possible outcome of quantum
processes right that that stretch from
the beginning until today that each of
them could have turned out one way
versus the way they did yielding
Universe in which we wouldn't be here
against these astounding odds were here
and to me that's the beginning of the
most fruitful compelling and satisfying
approach to finding some sense of
purpose or meaning because rather than
looking out to the universe which we see
in many philosophies and frankly many
religions looking out to the cosmos to
bestow upon us some Ultimate answers
some ultimate meaning some ultimate
purpose
this understanding of the cosmological
timeline and the astounding unlikeliness
of our own existence
turns the spotlight inward it turns the
spotlight to a recognition of how
astounding it is not only that we exist
but we have the powers that our
particulate Arrangement endows us with
look what we can do we can have this
conversation
we can figure out the past there aren't
many other life forms that we're aware
of that can do that we can imagine the
future again not many life forms have
been able to work out a testable science
that can give us insight into things
that haven't yet happened to the Future
and the power of the human mind to do
all that and and to create Beauty in the
world and to illuminate mystery in the
world and and to experience The Wonder
of it all
to me that is where a deep kind of
gratitude emerges and that gratitude is
for the mere existence of human beings
and it's not dependent upon whether
we're going to have some lasting Legacy
it rather is just focused on the fact
that we're here at all and that we can
do the things that we can do and with
that comes in appreciation which for me
is deeply compelling and satisfying
regardless of my understanding of how
evanescent it all is
do you fear death
I do and I think that
the fear of death is
one of the major driving forces of of
the human species both as a species as a
whole and as individuals and this is not
you know an original thought when I was
I guess way back in college I
encountered a book called the denial of
death by Ernest Becker who himself was
channeling and developing ideas of other
Rock one of the great early
psychologists who was in the Freudian
school to begin with and then really
plowed his own path and this idea that
we humans are a rare life form that not
only can we imagine the future as I
mentioned before but we recognize that
if we looked far enough into that future
we're not there we recognize that we're
mortal and that recognition of mortality
fights against the urge for
influence Legacy a
lasting part of us we urge that we don't
get washed away by the by the Relentless
Winds of time and yet that
is not the way the universe is
constructed and so the fear of
everything we love everything we care
about everything we develop everything
that we worry about and spend energy and
time on that it all goes away
to me is one of the deep insights and
the Deep motivators for how we humans
behave
have you ever inhabited a dark state of
mind for a prolonged period of time so
for instance contemplation of
suicide or ideation on the supposed
objective meaninglessness of the world
and that you have to find it
subjectively but maybe it was Fringe to
your sanity yeah well I would say that
I've never gotten thankfully to the
place of sort of suicidal ideation and
again you know anybody who has uh you
know seek out help and guidance because
there there are ways to get to a better
place but I have certainly
inhabited Dark Places and some of it has
come from the things that we're talking
about when you think about the cosmos
and the laws of physics and our little
tiny planet Earth just floating in this
vast perhaps infinitely vast Darkness
there is a way that if you take that in
emotionally as opposed to just purely
intellectually
it can take you to a place of of
darkness and fear foreboding and I have
explored that on occasion so how have
you gotten out of that well one solution
may be to separate the intellect and the
motion and just explore the vastness of
the cosmos intellectually rather than
emotionally because it may it may feel
you may feel daunted
or you could say hey look maybe the fact
that we're finite and temporarily bound
isn't what matters most because it's
like going to a suffering child and
saying oh that doesn't matter that the
child's being tortured by some serial
killer it's finite hahaha like that's
not that's that doesn't help anyone so
sure the fact that we're small spatially
or a small temporally yeah and and and
you know the answer to your question
there have been I mean without going
into great detail there certainly have
been periods of my life luckily they've
not been
incredibly long but there have certainly
been periods when I wasn't exactly sure
how to find my way out of the dark
space
and ultimately what really helped me was
along the lines of what you're saying to
blend the the human emotion which can be
Terror of mortality that can be a sense
of insignificance against the cosmic
order but to blend that with a
recognition that sure we may be
insignificant but
we as a species may have figured out
How the Universe began and how it
evolved and we may have figured out what
laws of physics are in operation both
here but also throughout the entirety of
an infinite Cosmos we may have figured
out laws that are relevant not just
today and yesterday but perhaps relevant
all the way
13.8 billion years ago and may continue
to be relevant a hundred billion or a
trillion or who knows how many years
into the future and so if you allow
yourself to feel part of that human
journey and that human achievement I
have found that that can
assuage some of the darkness and make
one feel a connection to a larger Cosmos
and that connection to that large or
Cosmos for me has certainly helped to
pull me from a place of smallness and
and feeling of darkness and
insignificance to at least a connection
that ameliorated those qualities and
those feelings
approximately how old were you when you
were going through this period if you
don't mind me asking I you know it's a
good question you know certainly there
was a a time in my 40s that I can that I
can point to
um there were episodes earlier like
right after college I went through a
kind of a rough spell there but it was
thankfully relatively short-lived
um and so it's been it's been periodic
but it hasn't been debilitating
and when I look at the things that I've
done that I value most
I can't help but think that those
periods were pretty vital toward being
able to do the things that I did so look
it's a life is a is a whole package
right and and that whole package for
some will involve periods that are less
comfortable than others from this
perspective was it mainly the paltryness
of existence or did you feel worthless
as a result or for some other reason an
apologies if it's getting personal but
it's just that many people including
myself like it's super helpful to see
people that you look up to as a hero
intellectually especially going through
what is common and emotional
yeah you know it definitely wasn't
feelings of worthlessness
in a sense it wasn't quite that personal
I mean obviously it was a a very
personal sensation and and a personal
challenge to um to overcome certain
things that made it difficult to feel to
feel happy and to feel alive
but it was never a sense of I Brian
Green I'm worthless it was more a sense
of
oh my God
like how does one live with the
understanding of
the fact that apparently we are just the
random output
of random conditions being Guided by a
particular set of rigid mathematical
rules
and if you think about that cognitively
it's kind of interesting and quirky but
if you think about it emotionally
it can really take you to a different
place
and and for me as I was saying before I
think the key to going forward was to
not be terrorized by those realizations
but find a way within those realizations
to feel a deep gratification and that's
a place that I've been able to get to
but it's relatively recent getting to
that place it's not as though as the 19
year old or a 20 year old this was
something that was right there and so it
really is tying together the emotional
and the cognitive into a narrative a
story that at least for me is an
individual leaves me feeling deeply
connected to a wider reality and no
longer feeling that sense of foreboding
at the apparent
randomness of it all
is it possible to find meaning and
disconnectedness I often hear that
connectedness is associated with meaning
but is it possible do you see a way that
you could be too connected and you feel
like okay let me just back off a bit
well it's a funny thing that you frame
it that way because anybody who knows me
who personally would not consider me
connected in the usual sense I don't
spend an enormous amount of time with uh
human beings
outside of my most immediate family you
know my my kids and wife like to joke of
the uh you know the lack of human
contact that I have Beyond a fairly
small group so I'm not talking about
Connection in that sense although for
some people that connection is utterly
vital and utterly Central to their being
I'm talking more of a kind of cosmic
connection a feeling of being integrated
into a wider reality because we're made
of the very same stuff as everything
else in reality we're Guided by the
various same laws as everything else in
reality we emerged by processes that
stretch from the beginning until today
as every other structure in the cosmos
has as well
and so if you take that in fully enough
and in the right light it makes you feel
part of the fabric of reality
and I think that's the connection that
to me is the one that has proven to be
the most important
have psychedelics informed either your
physics or your metaphysics
I can't really say in fact it's not
completely clear to me whether or not
I've actually ever had a psychedelic
experience no doubt you're referring to
the fact that on in some more recent
interviews I've opened up about certain
experiences uh that um at the time were
absolutely terrifying and in
conversation with people who know far
more about this Arena than I do
um their view is you know anything that
takes your mind to a different place
that ultimately you learn something from
fits within the genre of exploration of
Altered States Of Consciousness so
framing it in that way
um yeah I would say that
um I have not had many such experiences
but the the few that I have had
um I guess gave me the deepest sense of
how fragile ordinary cognition and
ordinary experiences you introduce a few
little molecules into the mind
and these molecules radically change
your experience I mean that's
mind-blowing isn't it I mean you know
cognitively we all know that what's
happening inside of our head is just the
cascading motion of particles going
through our brains neurons firing it's
all describable at the level of
particulate motion inside of our heads
okay good I got that cognitively now let
me just throw in a few more molecules
and all of a sudden the experience
changes radically
and so everything that that we you
usually think of as defining reality
which is our experience in an intuitive
level can be not completely off kilter
through some molecules and that's a
beautiful recognition and it opens you
up to the realization that our
experience is not tapping into the
reality
our experience is taking a reality and
interpreting it and molding it and
shaping it in a manner that our brains
do because of how they form through
evolution by natural selection across
the eons right our brains are the way
they are because our forebears survive
and they survive because their brains
were in a particular configuration and
allowed them to better navigate the
environment than their competitors
and that brain interprets the world
we can change that interpretation by
introducing new molecules and that is a
deeply
profound and eye-opening experience
if you could solve one problem an
academic one so not let's take off the
table world hunger or peace and so on
which one
and so this includes the hard problem of
Consciousness or philosophical problems
as well as physics ones which one do you
most want solved by you
uh well it's interesting and part of my
answer will depend on what the answer is
so I think that the solution to the hard
problem of Consciousness I suspect it's
not going to be very interesting
I suspect that the solution to the hard
problem of Consciousness will be
Consciousness just is it's a quality
that emerges when matter takes on a
particular organized form and undergoes
certain very orderly and organized
procedures and phenomena
and if that's the answer and I think
that is likely to be the answer then
count me out in terms of wanting to
solve it I think that may be the
solution if it's more interesting than
that if there's some Consciousness feel
that you know various religions talk
about or or something that we can't even
imagine and that's the root of
Consciousness yes then I'd love I'd love
to be part of the journey to solve it
that way but assuming that it's the more
boring but nevertheless you know
profoundly important Solution on what
the hard problem is then the other
questions that I would really love to be
part of finding the solution of is
what is time
is it just a secondary feature of the
world that we human beings find useful
in order to organize our perceptions of
the world or is time more fundamentally
woven into the fabric of reality you
know is there a realm of reality in
which there's no conception of time
because the conditions simply have not
gelled to the point where the conception
of time can even emerge or is there
always a notion of time because it's
just fundamentally part of how reality
is constructed I'd say that would be the
the one big one and then a lot allied
with that you know look I'd love to know
what the unified theory is Right I'd
love to know what
a thousand years from now
kindergarteners are going to learn in
their course on unified field theory if
that's the answer you know what is it
and where does it come from
we can have a final Theory whatever it
is general relativity plus Quantum and
can't what or maybe it's radically
different but whatever that ultimate
theory is
where did it come from
did someone in some super simulation
dream it up and we were just living out
or where in the world do these
fundamental laws and regularities and
patterns come from in essence really why
is there something rather than nothing I
mean it can't really get deeper than
that and by nothing I don't mean you
know empty space I don't mean nothing in
the sense of a void
I mean truly nothing no space no time no
quantum mechanics no mathematics no
platonic realm like why isn't there
nothing it seems that there could be
nothing so how did it transpire that
there is a something
that's the big one
do you think that a true toe or a good
toe is one that explains itself
well
whenever you talk about a theory of
everything and let me I will frame it
that way I never use the word toe myself
but you know whenever you talk about a
Theory of Everything
you have to say to yourself what is
embraced by everything
usually when we physicists throw it away
throw around not throw away when we
throw around the term Theory of
Everything we usually mean it in a very
limited everything we usually mean you
know the particles and the laws you know
the ingredients and the rules that's
what we mean by everything but given
that one can say but why are there any
particles why are there any rules and so
yeah your way of framing it that if that
Theory of Everything could somehow
establish its own inevitability
if that Theory of Everything somehow has
built within it that the lack of
existence of that theory of everything
would somehow be itself a logical
inconsistency
so that reality could not have this
Theory of Everything because reality is
we believe in some sense consistent that
would that would be deeply compelling
Dyson conjectured that the girdle
incompleteness theorem or one of them
applied to physics and so we may never
know at all I don't recall his argument
but I'm sure you've heard an argument
akin to this can you spell it out for
the audience and then where do you stand
on it you know I have to say I have
struggled myself
for a long time
to really know or at least have a feel
for the relevance of girdle's ideas
when it comes to the laws of physics
and um
there was a time when I tried to
convince myself that
because
girdles theorem itself relies upon
assumptions could we modify the
assumptions in such a way that
the new assumptions could be relevant to
the universe but the conclusion that
girdle came to would no longer be
relevant because the assumptions had
changed
and there are a handful of relatively
straightforward ways to do that
um and frankly I don't even haven't
thought about it in detail in quite some
time but I I remember going through and
saying aha all we have to do is imagine
a universe in which this is not true and
that Universe could be our unit like
para compact logic or I mean there are
ways in which you can go beyond the
limited set of assumptions that girdle
had and so I
more or less have convinced myself that
girdle's ideas need not imply that we
will somehow fundamentally be in an
undecidable situation when it comes to
understanding the Deep laws of the
universe it doesn't mean that girdle's
ideas might not apply they could but
they don't have to
and without realization I became less
interested in in really puzzling because
now we're in a realm that's so esoteric
and Abstract relative to the kind of
concrete problems like what's the dark
matter and what's the dark energy and
you know is there just a unified theory
of the particles of matter that we have
discovered it just felt
20 steps removed from those kind of deep
but really Hands-On questions that I
haven't spent a whole lot of time
thinking about it since speaking of time
do you believe time to be well maybe you
don't let's not say believe when you
were playing with some ideas earlier and
you're saying well time may be emergent
do you also believe space to be emergent
do you believe space time itself is
emergent
yeah I mean if if if time is emergent
it's hard for me to imagine that space
is not emerging too
again anybody who's uh spent a little
time thinking about the insights from
Einstein on
recognizes that space and time are so
deeply and intricately interwoven into
the fabric of space-time that sort of
pulling one apart and imagining it has
different properties space and time have
different properties it's not impossible
but it does fly in the face of pretty
much everything we've learned in the
last hundred years so
I certainly do Envision that if there's
a realm of reality in which time does
not apply because as we're saying before
the conditions haven't yet allowed for a
conception of time to emerge the same
would almost certainly be true of space
so the real way of saying it is is there
a realm of reality in which there's no
conception of space-time
and and it's hard for me to imagine what
that is but that's because I've got this
brain that is constrained by what my
ancestors did and that brain is one that
is so tied to a conception of reality in
which space and time are the
architecture within which
events take place that it's really hard
for us to think about a reality in which
there isn't space time and so I I wish I
could give some really good uh example
or insight into what that would be like
but it would be some kind of reality in
which the language that we use would not
talk about when things are happening and
the language that we use would not talk
about where things are happening the
language would somehow be
beneath that more fundamental than that
and it's not that scientists don't have
some ideas for what this might be like
but I'd say that we do lack
the Deep picture and the Deep story of
how we would really articulate and
navigate a reality absent space-time
have you had a chance to go through
wolfram's Theory his project on physics
I wish I had you know yeah I mean you
know
uh yeah you you know Steve's a great guy
and he's a friend and um
we talk about things on occasion
and um I wish I had more time to to
spend with him because it's always
Illuminating when we do spend some time
together
but I've I've not
I don't feel like I fully grasp the
approach that he's taking
um and why I oh well well I can aptly
throw this on myself
um so it could well be limitations in my
own thinking and limitations the amount
of energy and effort that I've expended
to understand his approach more fully
um but I get stuck on trying to really
understand whether the formalism as he
envisions it
is it actually fundamentally different
from the more traditional formalism he
would say yes as far as I can tell but
as I have looked at it on occasion it
has struck me that it's not obvious to
me that it is as different as He
suggests and again I could be wrong on
this and it could be that I just haven't
put enough effort or energy into it I'm
glad that he's pursuing his approach
it's not within the confines of the
traditional established environment is
not doing it inside of a physics
department or math department you know
he has the resources and and and the
creative energies to make his own
environment and find his own
collaborators and and more power to
anybody who who has the capacity to do
that whether it's going to Bear the
fruit that he envisions I don't know but
I'd say the same thing about what we're
doing here like we've been beating down
on string theory you know since you know
1984 at least you know the the big first
Revolution but since 1968 if you want to
go further back to the first glimmers of
string theory and where are we now 2023
that's a lot of years right so you can
say the same thing you know so so I
don't feel qualified to really judge the
approach but I I just feel that I
haven't fully wrapped my head around
whether or not it's fundamentally
different from what we do
quite a few thoughts firstly what
progress has been made in string theory
in the past say two decades
yeah well that's a a nice big chunk of
time and I'd say you know the the big
thing in the last two decades has been
the the recognition
that
there's a connection between gravity and
quantum mechanics
that I don't think we sufficiently
appreciated 20 25 years ago I mean I
mean take my book just as As One Moment
In Time a snapshot in the elegant
Universe I was published in 1999.
and in that book I I very clearly lay
out there's this Theory called general
relativity describing Gravity the big
stuff
I lay out how there is this other Theory
called quantum mechanics describing the
small stuff and we want to put them all
together to have a unified theory of the
big n the small but we're having trouble
doing that and then I go into the book
and how String Theory seems to be making
progress and putting the big and the
small together if I was writing that
book today and in some sense I am
because I'm adding a chapter for the
25th anniversary of the elegant universe
and and one of the things that I'm
emphasizing is
there's now a lot of evidence
that gravity and quantum mechanics in
some sense
are kind of the same Theory they
are already in some strange sense
combined
and this was completely unexpected based
on anything that we knew 20 or so 20
plus years ago so within for instance
general relativity there are these
structures you made reference to one of
them earlier called wormholes which are
tunnels in the fabric of space going
from one space-time location to another
through a kind of shortcut that's
general relativity and quantum mechanics
there's this weird thing called quantum
entanglement where two widely separated
particles can act as though they're
right next to each other even though
they can be on opposite ends of the
universe
and really nobody thought there was a
connection between these two ideas until
people like Lenny suskind and Juan Mall
the Cena and and a variety of other
influential scientists too many to name
them all
gave evidence that in some sense
wormholes and entanglement are kind of
the same thing they kind of feel the
same if you think about it
Wormhole it's connecting one point in
space time with another through a
shortcut entanglement is connecting one
particle in space time with another
particle in some sense through a
shortcut because they're acting as
though they're right next to each other
and so this is the beginning the tip of
an iceberg of a deep and and very
powerful story which is showing that
structures and general relativity and
structures and quantum mechanics are
already deeply connected and deeply
entwined and so the unification program
May ultimately not be described in terms
of putting gravity and quantum mechanics
together the way I described it and many
did of course in the earlier days but it
may be more deeply understanding general
relativity more deeply understanding
quantum mechanics and more deeply
understanding how they are part and
parcel of the same theoretical structure
so the recent results by Google of the
ER equals epr is that over hyped
is that under hyped I also can you
explain the results to the audience
yeah so this is a little bit
controversial there there have been some
um feathers ruffled by uh some some
recent activity and what the idea is
that if for instance what I said a
moment ago is true that there's a deep
connection between
wormholes and general relativity and
entanglement in quantum physics then a
number of influential physicists pointed
out that by doing certain calculations
on a quantum computer you would in some
sense
be simulating
a wormhole in general relativity because
Quantum Computing is all about
leveraging quantum entanglement between
qubits
and so there was a recent paper and it
was making use of the quantum
computational capacities at Google
and I think the I think the
um the kerfuffle is more about language
than anything else because some of the
folks who were carrying out this work
this is like Maria spirapalu and and Joe
Lickin and Daniel Jefferson so on there
was at least some part of the
description which made it sound like
they claimed to have created a wormhole
in the quantum computer at Google that
actually created a wormhole by carrying
out this Quantum computation and and I
guess some people would be more
comfortable by saying they were modeling
a wormhole or kind of simulating a
wormhole as opposed to actually creating
a wormhole you know one comment I saw by
the the really deeply insightful
um Quantum computational physicist Scott
Aronson was saying to say that you
created a wormhole in in
undertaking this quantum computer
simulation would be tantamount to saying
that every time you drew a worm on a
piece of paper you created or almost
like how do you distinguish between
modeling something and the something
and I think that distinction perhaps
According to some was lost in some of
the
ways in which the results were
articulated
um but putting the the the controversy
or the bit of uh uh kerfuffle to the
side it's a very very interesting piece
of work in which doing a Quantum
computation and appropriately
interpreting it you could see within
that computation the kinds of phenomenon
that you would associate with a wormhole
and that's a beautiful thing because it
now is a very concrete realization of
what I was saying before an answer to a
question of what's new in the last 20
years what's new is here you're doing
something that's purely quantum
mechanical you're carrying out a Quantum
computation on a quantum computer and
then by analyzing it appropriately
you're saying oh my god look in there
we're seeing exactly what we'd expect in
a particular kind of wormhole
and so the connection between general
relativity and quantum mechanics becomes
that much more apparent
the uncontroversial statement is that
they've simulated a wormhole or modeled
a wormhole
I don't want to speak at a turn because
I want to speak for either side of this
debate but I would say that I think
that's the linchpin of some of the
controversy and so it feels less
important to me
when thought of in that light I'm just
interested in how curious and wonderful
it is that general relativity and
quantum mechanics are brushing up
against each other in a manner that we
really wouldn't have anticipated with
the level of our understanding 20 25
years ago
okay now speaking about what's overhyped
or potentially under hyped what are some
of the applications of category Theory
to high energy physics
oh goodness gracious wrong person to
talk about you know I've read some of
the uh the papers on this stuff but I
don't feel sufficiently expert to weigh
in on that at all so sorry all right no
problem so there are different toes like
Garrett lisi's like Eric Weinstein from
Peter white and I'm curious
have you had a chance to look into any
of those like lisi's E8 or or Eric
Weinstein's geometric Unity or Peter
White's euclidean twister
I didn't even know that Peter Boyd had
put forward
um a particular idea so again I'll have
to uh claim ignorance on that front but
um the Garrett leasy stuff unless
there's something radically new in
recent years certainly when he first
gained a little bit of attention for the
ideas he was put forward
um you know I I have to say I relied
upon a good friend who I've known for 40
years perhaps
um Jacques disler at a University of
Texas who did a wonderful series of blog
posts that analyze the claims and made
it quite clear that there wasn't a whole
lot there there when it came to the
Gareth leasy stuff and that that
certainly convinced me that it really
wasn't worth my time to delve into it
you know life is short if you chase
every idea that someone raises the flag
on and says here it is you wind up never
being able to do any of your own work
um and what was the other one oh oh the
wine shark Weinstein I don't know much
yeah I don't know much about again in
any detail so I I can't comment but I
guess you know I've not I've not
encountered uh anything beyond quantum
gravity which I don't work on I don't I
don't study but I certainly respect
um the results that that Community has
put forward and you know
um while some people take exception with
certain things that Lee smullen one of
the leaders of that field has said about
String Theory I I sort of don't take
those things personally and I focus more
on on the ideas and I think they've done
some some wonderful work in
understanding connections between
General activity and and quantum
mechanics but you know one would say
that I'm biased I don't see anything
that's achieved the level of refinement
and sophistication and insight that
string theory has provided nothing that
I've seen remotely holds a candle to the
kinds of insights especially the ones
that we were just talking about a moment
ago which are which are both deep and
surprising but you know even before that
you know the capacity to have a theory
that is
quantum mechanical and has general
relativity embedded
and is able to have within it the
symmetries of the standard model of
particle physics and the particles in
the standard model and naturally is
within their Theory that's able to give
us insight into
things like the entropy of black holes
which again you know Loop quantum
gravity has its own insights but I think
the string theoretic ones are are deeply
impressive and so there have been so
many small achievements along the way
yeah we haven't gotten the big one which
would be an experiment that somehow
reveals that this Approach To Nature is
the right approach but there have been
so many achievements over the course of
the last 50 years that I haven't feel
compelled to look for another approach
because we've got a rich wondrous deep
compelling theory that we're in the
midst of unraveling
and so that feels to me a very strong
pull relative to you know somebody comes
up with some idea raises their hand and
said now look at what I have got and
that to me I'm glad there are people who
are doing it but it's typically not the
thing will grab my attention away from
the focus work that that I'm doing that
we're doing as a community what would be
the other people in the ring that you
see as competent boxers that are
opponents to string theory or or perhaps
it's not a competition they're all
clearing for the same they're all
fighting toward the same goal so what
else is there so there's Loop but again
that's not a toll per se it's quantum
gravity approach unless there's some
other development I'm unaware of do you
mind listing some
no I wouldn't I I guess people say to
this first of all like I said before I I
typically don't use the language
toe or Theory of Everything and it's not
because of the um the abbreviation of
the acronym I think that the whole
conception of everything is an odd one
so when you talk about Loop quantum
gravity you know if you have a theory
that is able to embrace general
relativity and quantum mechanics in some
calculable and coherent mathematical
form
that's huge right I wouldn't say that it
somehow is subordinate to string theory
because within String Theory you know
perhaps you can also put the standard
model particle physics most direct you
know if Loop quantum gravity works you
will be able to use it as an overarching
framework and then put in quote unquote
everything else put in matter I have no
doubt that that this is a a potential
future if indeed Loop quantum gravity is
the right way to go so I wouldn't
somehow diminish it and say well string
theory is a theory of everything and
loop quantum gravity is not I don't I
don't think that way sure at all I mean
to me the big question is you know what
do we do about general relativity and
quantum mechanics and what's becoming
clear as I mentioned before
is that the idea of trying to meld them
together May itself have been somewhat
wrong-headed they may already be melded
together and it's up to us to understand
how that melding actually works I mean
as you know well once quantum mechanics
came on the scene in the 1920s
there was this approach developed called
quantization
where you took ideas from the
pre-quantum world classical physics and
you found a kind of algorithm
for making them quantum mechanical and
that algorithm is called quantization
take Newton's ideas make them quantum
mechanical you know and and and that was
the Rhythm that was the approach that we
took for a long time that may not be the
right approach it may not be you take
Einstein's ideas of General activity and
you quantize them they may already have
quantum mechanics within them and that
that's the Deep new and exciting Insight
so he asked me sort of what are the sort
of competitors or candidates
you know we'll we'll certainly
I consider as I mentioned before the
Luke quantum gravity community
many colleagues many friends in that
world and I respect what they are doing
I think as I mentioned that this string
theoretic approach has achieved more and
it feels like it's giving us more
surprising and and detailed insights but
no doubt people would say partly your
view is colored by the fact that you
know since I was a graduate student
that's been more or less the domain
within which I've walked none of the
other ideas that I've seen described and
again I full well say I do not
investigate them all because I don't
have the time but I have not seen
anything else that rises to that level
of achievement or sophistication the
reason behind my question is that I'm
working on a paper with a colleague
Carlos zapeda where we're going to do an
inventory of the candidates for
unification attempts between gravity and
quantum mechanics so maybe don't you
don't want to call it tells whatever
let's just call the tolls for the sake
of this and then also some deciderata on
the side like does it explain so and so
on and there's some uncontroversial list
on Wikipedia of the outstanding problems
in physics and putting a check mark like
a matrix with one on the x-axis one on
the y-axis
and so I wanted to know well I'm asking
different physicists and also
mathematicians who work in physics what
are the
different candidates that should go
there and I know that you mentioned that
there are several people who raised a
hand as difficulty can't follow every
single one who says I have a toe the toe
by Lisi and and Weinstein and Eric
Wolfram they're of a different quality
than the average person who emails and
says that they have a toe that is in
mathematical sophistication maybe not
rigor but hey the elements of a toll
even Quantum field theory is not
entirely rigorous but the the point is
in terms of mathematical sophistication
they're in a different League so I'm
curious what else goes there and then I
wanted to do a waiting like it's it's a
bit unfair to say s032 solves 7 out of
the 15.
but wolf runs only solves 5 out of the
15. however wolfram's working on it in a
basement maybe a basement in a lovely
house but like in a basement and and
there's let's say a thousand people
working on sl32 across decades or
heterotic eight or whatever it may be so
then I was like how do I do that waiting
and then but anyway so it's a fun
project
and I just wanted some some help with it
and I wanted to hear what your thoughts
were and what else do you think I should
consider putting in it or not putting in
it
look I mean it sounds like fun and I'm
sure I'd enjoy reading it when it comes
out but the but the interesting thing is
to most researchers in the field
the work is all about the details
and and you're right that we all receive
these letters
in the mail and sometimes they're
actually kind of heartbreaking I've
gotten letters from people who have been
in that basement that you just made
reference to not a particularly nice one
I would imagine working out the final
Theory of Everything I remember one
gentleman wrote to me and I'm I think he
was on the level he was saying how he's
been working on this for 20 25 years his
wife left him his kids left him because
the only thing he cared about was
working out this Theory and he finally
had the theory and it sent it to me and
it looked like every other theory that I
get through that particular medium all
sorts of graphs and lines and
interconnected shapes and you're like oh
my God you know this is probably insane
I mean not insane in some medically
verifiable sense but it's deeply sad
that someone
um who has the same urge that we have
right and wants to figure it all out is
somehow likely being misled by certain
kinds of patterns or certain kinds of
geometrical shapes that really have no
bearing on the final answer the number
of times you get Communications of the
sort where it's all about working out
ratios of like pi to the ninth divided
by e to the seventh you know time you
know and and they work out to like 12 or
15 decimal places and they find some
pattern in the numbers and yeah it hurts
inside to imagine someone spending their
life doing something like that which is
meaningless
and so yes that category of work is
quite different
from any of the other ideas that you've
put forward
um but in the end of the day you know
people vote with what they work on and
string theory has attracted a great deal
of people to work on and by strength
year I mean now something broader than
what I would have meant say in 1990 or
2000 now String Theory now is any work
that uses the ingredients or the
insights or the mathematical formalism
that was part of the early development
of string theory so now you know people
who are working on connections between
gravity general relativity and quantum
mechanics entanglement as we described
before would I call that string theory
per se I don't know it would have been
very unfamiliar to a string theorist say
from 1980 but that's what progress is
it's it's wherever the ideas Lead You So
as a community
it's hard for me to compare anything to
the string theory Community for the
level of insight and and the level of
achievement so sure I mean it's nice to
lay out like in a matrix in a chart you
know the various approaches that that
serious scientists as opposed to perhaps
untrained folks in basements
um what serious scientists have been
focusing their attention on but I I
really don't think anything comes close
to what the string theory Community
broadly defined has achieved and again I
do have great respects as I mentioned
for the loop quantum gravity Community
but none of the others for me really are
are developed to a point that are worthy
of exploration and tension at least not
yet
what advice do you have for people who
are interested in physics like seriously
interested in physics but aren't able to
go to a university for whatever reason
maybe they're older now and they feel
like they don't want to go back they
have not enough time or they just don't
have the money or for whatever life
circumstance
yeah well look you know I never want to
discourage people
there may be a a ramanujan
in our midst you know someone who's
level of perspicacity is so off scale
that they don't need the traditional
training and they don't need the
traditional environment and then they
can produce things that you know I
forget exactly the quote but
mathematician GH Hardy when looking at
some of the theorems that ramanujan had
sent him said something like you know
if these are true he's the greatest
mathematician if these are not true he's
an even greater mathematician for having
thought them up when they're not
actually true I mean you know so so if
there's somebody like that uh wow more
power to them and and they can pursue
these kinds of ideas on their own or
maybe through brief Communications but
for the vast majority of people of the
sort that you're describing it is really
tough
to do this outside of a community of
co-workers I mean the way we physicists
typically work you know I'm in my office
at Columbia students and grad students
and post-docs and and seminars and
informal conversations and you read this
paper and you hear that idea you talk to
that person you start to develop this
collaboration that collaboration it's
just really hard to do
physics without that and so if one is
not in that world and one is somewhat
older it's really tough to break in and
for most people they they don't have the
financial resources to just give up
their life and go back to school
especially with the fact that I mean you
know maybe things are changing but
you know it's tough to get a faculty job
if you get your PhD at like 70. it's
just unlikely I'm using extreme numbers
to avoid anybody like jumping down my
throat in some ageism because you know
but you know what I'm saying the typical
root the typical root is someone gets
their PHD at a relatively young and
Society views it as more energetic
fertile Age and and and and and then
they get a faculty job and and they're
often running as part of the community
and when you when you delay that it's
really really hard I mean I have known
and you know individuals who loved I
remember I'm thinking of one guy in
particular love mathematics and he went
back and got his PhD at a relatively
Advanced age which wasn't old but
relative Advantage compared to the norm
and got himself a really nice teaching
job at a university
and as far as I can tell I haven't
spoken to one is quite happy
because he's spending time in the
community of ideas that he finds most
exciting but
um it's tough that's rare that's really
tough so you know I guess the advice
would be
maybe you can find enough gratification
from reading about the ideas and maybe
going to a local University when they
have a seminar series maybe you can you
know and maybe through that you can find
inroads into your local community at a
local University and maybe even begin
some collaboration on on some kind of
project
but it's it's not an easy path and
certainly not if one wants to make it
there
sort of career and and for them to make
a living from it that's really tough if
you're not in a traditional trajectory
would an analogy be if someone wants to
learn martial arts sure you could do so
on your own you can watch YouTube videos
but there is something about grappling
with other people using your body with
someone who's living rather than a
wooden machine
there's something about the group
dynamic or does that an analogy fail no
I think it's a really good analogy and I
think I may use it going forward so
thank you on that one but because
um but the number of times
you know I'm reasonably well
accomplished right the number of times
when I've been working on something I'm
completely stuck I try this I try that
it's just not just not happening right
then I'll meet with a few people you
know here Colombia collaboration we Chit
Chat talk about oh boom now we know
where to go where did the idea come from
none of us had the idea going in to that
exchange but yet somehow in the midst of
that grappling if I go back to your
metaphor the the the potential idea
emerged and and so without that
um it's very hard to make progress
have you ever collaborated with Ed
Whitton
collaborated no but worked
um uh uh right next to him yes in the
sense of back in the 1990s oh my God I'm
getting old but back in the 1990s I was
at the institute for advanced study and
um we had an idea I had a particular
idea of something I wanted to prove that
the fabric of space could rip and uh Ed
is at the institute for Advantage so I
told him about this idea and thought it
was exciting I was working with a couple
other people Paul asmold Dave Morrison
and Edward started to work on his own
version
didn't take anything from us he was just
went a completely different direction
but yet converged on exactly the same
question and it was among the most
exciting times that I've had in physics
because like we knew he was closing in
on it we were closing in on it we knew
that he's a million times smarter than
we are so we had to work the million
times harder and faster to try to get
there and not be completely scooped and
basically at the same time late in the
fall I guess of 1992 it was we within
days came to the same conclusion from
completely different approaches and so
we were right right there you know Head
to Head it was an incredibly exciting
time uh but yeah he's again
you know one of those figures whose
intellect is just hard to fathom I was
speaking to Richard Orchards and he said
Ed Whitton is terrifying
that I said well why and he said that he
puts out as side effects whole other
fields like the Witten invariance like
cyborg yeah
you have to tell you you know it's funny
a friend of mine was at the institute
for advanced study over a summer and the
place that kind of cleared out and and I
think Edward was there and this friend
of mine was there I won't give his name
in case he wouldn't want me to share it
but they were kind of sharing a wall
their offices were right next to each
other and so my friend was slogging away
doing his calculations you know hitting
dead ends and all through the summer he
kept hearing tap tap tap tap as Ed was
typing out paper after paper after paper
as if he was just sort of sitting there
and the ideas were sufficiently formed
they didn't even have to write anything
out he could go right from brain to
finished paper and my friend was like
you sit there and you're like what am I
doing why am I in this field
you know I can't you I can't but but but
that's actually an important thing
there is a place where so many people
can contribute sort of back to the
question we had before
while it's harder for the person who's
not gone to graduate school or is
working in the basement to really make
that contribution
kids who go to undergraduate then go to
graduate there's so many ways for so
many different people with so many
different
levels of intellectual capacity and
level of insight to contribute and to
contribute in vital ways and so you
don't have to only be an Edward Whitten
in order that you advance the field and
and so it's absolutely the case
yeah how do you not feel demoralized if
you're working on the same problem as Ed
Whitton or synonym for Ed Whitton
so you work on a different problem or or
what or you try to collaborate look I
mean
it is so I you know I gave you one
example where we were working on the
same problem in a sense as Edward
Whitton and and the fact that we got to
the Finish Line at the same time was
again you know one of those great
achievements that that I will always
remember for Edward it was just another
day at the office you know
um but having said that
I think it's very important that you
pick your problems carefully
you don't want to take I don't like to
take a problem that every other
physicist deems as the most important
and they're all working on it that's
never been my Approach my Approach has
always been I'm gonna find that corner
that appeals to me that corner that I
feel like I can at my own pace I'll work
hard but at my own pace I can make
Headway make progress and contribute
something bring it out to the world and
then maybe excite people to work on that
I mean that's you know I I one of the
big things that I did some years ago is
called mirror symmetry which was uh
developing certain properties of higher
dimensional spaces that are relevant for
string theory and when we were working
on this it was a really small community
that was working it was really us and
one other group in Texas Philip
candelison who is grouped down in Texas
and so it was really exciting we were
competing against each other there but
we were in close communication but it
wasn't like a thousand other groups
around the world were all battered and
it's just us and so you know we got
hours he got his results our group got
our results he put people got excited
and then the field took off and now like
mirror symmetry has become a whole field
of mathematics that has developed over
decades I no longer even recognize the
things that happen in this field because
it got so mathematical and so beyond my
particular interest which is really from
the physics standpoint but that's a
great place to be work in your own
Corner come up with something put it out
there start a field and then the field
takes off and God bless everybody who
works on it
your current interest is time or one of
them the emergence of time
yeah I mean that it's a big question
though it's not as though you sit down
at your desk and you're like okay where
where does time begin you know I it's
not a question you hit head on I think
it's the kind of question that you hit
obliquely
and for instance I would imagine that
this work being done on wormholes and
quantum entanglement
taking general relativity and
understanding its inherent quantum
mechanical aspects I anticipate that
insight into a deep question such as the
origin of time will ultimately emerge
from that but not from a head-on
approach but rather from a more indirect
approach do you agree with or find
interesting Carlo ravelli's views on
time he has this book the order of time
and Lisa Mullen has his own views too
which I believe is a realist and then
Carlo believes it's more relational or
an emergent
and then Julian Barber
yeah so I think they're all interesting
yeah I think they're all interesting
ideas you know
um
I think that
ultimately
the the question of the the fundamental
nature of time is going to require
scientific insights Beyond those that we
currently have so I'm always interested
to hear
thoughts on the nature of time and so
Rebellion the relational quality of
space-time that resonates with me I
think there's definite powerful truth in
there uh I've seen papers of Lee's
talking about the way in which time can
emerge from an earlier temporal quality
a kind of way in which the future is
built from the present as opposed to
already in some sense a temporal
Dimension being out there I think it's
quite interesting Julian Barber
um I I remember being very excited about
the initial ideas and then I read his
book and there was one paragraph where I
felt the heart of the idea was put
forward
and it felt to me that he'd redefined
the problem for me in a way that didn't
feel as interesting any longer I don't
know if there's been developments since
then so it's all just to say that yeah
there time is a big mystery
always interested to hear people's take
on it but in the end of the day I think
it's going to take deeper scientific
insight and what's happening now in
string theory broadly defined in
understanding the quantum mechanical
qualities of general relativity the
intrinsic quantum mechanical qualities
of general relativity I think that's
where the new ideas are going to come
from before we wrap I have a choice for
you we can I have a couple physics
questions or a couple more philosophical
questions do you have a preference uh
you can do a blend whatever you whatever
you think is good all right all right so
I know that you have an explored
category Theory much but have you
explored geometric algebra or geometric
calculus
you know I have dabbled but not enough
to feel like I can provide any insight
compared to the people who really know
the subjects that I probably would save
those questions for subsequent guests
who are more in that space sure sure
what is the swampland the swampland
conjectures
yeah so the swampland conjectures
have to do with the following
question
when you have a theory that does a
really good job at describing say the
physics that we can see low energy
physics is the physics that we can see
does that theoretical description have
what's known as an UltraViolet
completion that is can that low energy
physics be augmented into a theory that
will agree with that low energy physics
but work at arbitrarily High energies or
is this just kind of an approximate
theory that works at low energies but
doesn't admit
an UltraViolet completed ultra high
energy doesn't emit the high energy
completion that is it cannot be extended
to arbitrarily High energies and the
swamp playing idea is to delineate
theories that may have a low energy
Incarnation but don't admit a full
completion to the entire energy spectrum
and and the the thought According to
some of the swamp limit ideas is that
the swamp plant is pretty big many many
of the theories that perhaps look like
they may be candidates for theories that
could be extended to arbitrarily High
energies they can't that they are
fundamentally inconsistent
and and that would be a that's a
potentially powerful idea because after
all our goal is to winnow down the
number of
candidate theories for the final Theory
and a final Theory would work at any
energy scale and if it can establish
that a great many theories that look
like they were contenders at low
energies that they don't admit an
extension to arbitrarily High energies
then they get eliminated from the
competition
and so you get to winnow out a whole
class of theories that don't
stand this test of completion to
arbitrarily High Energies
so what's meant by you can take a low
effect sorry a low energy Theory and it
works at the low energy but then for
some you may be able to augment them and
then their UV complete what's meant by
augment what's a valid augmenting so
that what I mean is you can augment
Newtonian Theory to get special relative
video I don't know if like does that
mean Newtonian like I don't know what
augment means yeah so so usually these
ideas are formulated where you've
actually got a mathematical formulation
of a given Theory say perhaps even
within String Theory itself and then you
can simply ask is this a self-consistent
theory in the sense that you can use it
that Matt that very mathematical
formulation at arbitrarily High Energies
and if you can't then it properly should
be
consigned to the swamp land because it
doesn't admit an extension to or an
application perhaps would be a better
way of saying it to arbitrarily High
energies
um and so you know this is an idea that
cumren vaffa and collaborators was You
Know instrumental in developing
um and it it you know I wouldn't say
that it has
um
um flattened all of the open questions
when it comes to theories like string
theory but it has sharpened them because
anytime you have a test in some sense
for whether or not a theory is fully
consistent works at arbitrarily High
energies and I should say high energies
mean short distances so does the theory
work at arbitrarily short distances if
it somehow is inconsistent at
sufficiently Short distances that's a
good thing for the project because now
you can throw that theory away
is consistency the same as
self-consistency
or is are those separate usually well
usually so unfortunately our ability to
probe the real physics of the real world
it arbitrarily short distances is highly
constrained by the equipment that we
have and so we'd love it
if consistency meant sure internal
consistency but also consistency with
observations that we might make of you
know physics down to 10 to the minus 25
or 10 to the minus 30 centimeters you
know that would be beautiful but but
because our ability to probe such Realms
is limited by our technology for the
most part yeah we're talking about
internal self-consistency uh okay
firstly is internal consistency the same
as self-consistency just so I can get
the terminology clear
yeah I mean it's just a statement of as
a mathematical structure
do you find any divergences do you find
any incurable Infinities or other
mathematical maladies do they emerge
when you try to apply this Theory to
arbitrarily short distance or
arbitrarily High Energies
and yeah you're not you're not talking
about observation at this point because
you don't have the observations sorry a
self-consistent theory would be UV
complete and a UV complete Theory would
be self-consistent or no like there's oh
yeah and if you if you have a true UV
complete Theory almost by definition
it's consistent because the completion
means that you've been able to
formulate the theory in a way that you
can apply it arbitrarily short distances
arbitrarily High energies that's what UV
completed is okay let's end with your
thoughts on simulation Theory
or sorry the simulation hypothesis yeah
uh well
um look
um
it's certainly the case
that as
um computational systems have become
more and more sophisticated their
ability to simulate the real world
seemingly is getting better and better
we see this with you know going from
video games to the most sophisticated
you know virtual reality
and so certainly one can imagine that at
some point in the future we will have
computational systems that are so
sophisticated that
they are able to have within them
collections of bits and bytes running
around that may themselves have
self-awareness now
that's the big unknown
can you have a computational system that
is itself self-aware that it has you
know some sort of Consciousness that
goes back to the question that we
started with early on I don't know the
answer to that but let's assume the
answers yet big assumption let's assume
the answer is yes
well then you're in an interesting
circumstance because
you can ask yourself
how many real universes in the sense of
solid tables and chairs are there well
we're kind of aware of one
and it's very hard to create new ones if
I challenge you to create a new real
Universe you don't know how to do it
create a new Big Bang nobody really
knows how to do that but if I ask you
how many of these simulated universes
are there again assuming that we've
gotten to the point say in the future
when we're able to simulate worlds of
the conscious beings there could be a
gazillion simulated universes you know
some kid just comes home late at night
and flips on the
computer and says let me just simulate
one more Universe with these and these
parameters it just flips it up and the
computer just simulates it and within
that simulation our further conscious
beings so then the question to ask
yourself is what's the likelihood that
right now we are in
the simulation
and if you sort of play the odds in the
most naive way you say well there's only
one real universe
but they're a gazillion gazillion
gazillion of these simulated worlds
and so the odds would seem to suggest
that we are in a simulated world just by
sheer force of the numbers and
probabilities
so do I believe that do I think that we
are in a simulation right now I can't
say that I do if you're to really
challenge me why I don't I don't really
have a good response beyond the fact
that I've never seen a simulation that
can do this
but you know that may simply be that the
simulator is so good that the simulator
is hidden from me the fact that I'm in a
simulation and I agree that if I
extrapolate from where computation was
40 years ago it's where it is today sort
of exponential growth in its ability to
do things that seem real then you know
don't go 40 years hence assuming we
don't blow ourselves up go A Thousand
Years hence and now you can really
imagine that there are these simulations
and we could well be in one of them so
I don't feel like I have a strong
refutation of the possibility that I'm
in a simulation but damn I certainly I I
can't say that I think or believe that I
am
man thank you so much for your time it's
been a pleasure I do have a last
question from Charlie from The Institute
for arts and ideas he sent this to me
and he's like Kurt can you please if
you're speaking to Brian I would love if
you could mention this so I'll chat it
here and I can say it aloud if that's
all right
so it's actually two uh
I can uh okay okay why don't you read it
yeah Charlie Barnett from The Institute
of Arts and ideas says
hi Brian almost a year ago to this day
you were featured on a panel at the IAI
so the institute for arts and ideas with
Michael Shermer Sabine hostenfelder and
Eric Weinstein Eric Weinstein who is a
mathematical physicist at Harvard said
that string theory had a terrible
culture in the 1980s that was in the
process of resolving itself
in response to this you sympathize and
said that there was a sense of
unreasonable exuberance that many
thought string theory was the final
Theory but it also seemed that Eric was
slightly exaggerating how bad the
culture was what do you think he was
referring to and could you maybe comment
more broadly about how one can ensure
that bias doesn't creep into scientific
theories
yeah I mean you know you know briefly
put
there there was a sentiment in the 80s I
mean I was I was there as in thick of it
as a graduate student mostly not as a
faculty member
and there was a sentiment that we were
approaching the end of physics
it was naive
but it was genuine it wasn't as though
people were making it up I mean you
can't imagine well you can but
if you weren't actually part of it
perhaps someone can't really feel the
visceral excitement that had taken hold
of a segment of the physics Community I
mean there I was a graduate student at
Oxford in 1984 1985
and every Wednesday or something like
that when when the free prints were
finally delivered to the physics
department The Graduate students two
others and myself in particular
we would like tear open the envelopes to
see the next result and we'd take that
paper and compare to what we were doing
we'd go upset and we were working like
you know 15 hours a day
you know I go to sleep at two in the
morning I'd wake up at seven I'd ride my
bike to the physical because it was just
like oh my God like it was all coming
together
which is all just to say it was genuine
the excitement was genuine but the
downside of that kind of excitement is
if someone's not working on string
theory at that time I can well imagine
they feel like a complete Outsider that
they're completely excluded that nobody
cares about what they're working on or
what they are doing and and I know
people who have described that
experience to me and I don't know if
that was Eric's experience or if there
was something particular that happened I
just don't know I don't know him
personally sure I've done that event and
so forth but I do know people who from a
more personal perspective have described
how alienated the excitement and the
string theory Community made them feel
back in those days
and and so I get it and and I wish it
wasn't that way but I guess the point
that I was making last year and the
point that I make again here it wasn't
malicious it wasn't like folks said
let's exclude everybody else is not
working on this sacred it wasn't like
that it was just that people were so
wrapped up in what they were doing and
so excited by what they were doing that
there wasn't a lot of energy or time
left in the community to pay attention
to things that were happening in in in
the surrounding and when it came to jobs
there were real implications for this
you know in those days
more strength here is got the postdocs
and got the faculty jobs because of the
excitement and you can well imagine that
somebody who is working hard and doing
really good work but outside of string
theory maybe said let me in I want a job
like I want a postdoc I want to I get it
and I totally
empathize with that but it's just that
when it's framed as though string
theorists were like a malicious
community that were sort of barring the
doors against it wasn't like that at all
it was just coming from whatever Alan
Green's you know irrational exuberance
you know it was exuberant and was it
irrational not irrational but it was
perhaps a little too much
because the more seasoned researchers
and physicists at that time knew that
ultimately the excitement would die down
and the theory would need to mature and
be developed and and that's what we've
been doing so I think that's sort of my
best answer that it was coming from a
good place it wasn't coming from a place
of exclusion
thank you Professor thank you for
spending so much time with me and I want
to know well people want to know where
can they find out more about you and
what you're working on next and what are
the URLs the social media
yeah you know I I I need to be a little
bit more active in that realm you know
sometimes I use Twitter my kids tell me
I should use Instagram maybe I'll start
doing that I don't know Tick Tock maybe
I think I'm too old for that but you
know the world Science Festival is
probably the best place we are creating
all sorts of I think really interesting
content and so people should sign up for
the world science social newsletter and
that certainly where a lot of my focus
has been in terms of bringing signs to
the public
um and yeah if you happen to be uh in
the Toronto area on the 26th and you
said it's next week because relative to
when this goes out yeah come by to the
program at Roy Thompson Hall I think
you'll enjoy it sort of an evening
exploration of the Universe from sort of
Soup To Nuts great and just to be clear
that's January 26 2023 evening time I'm
assuming when whatever it is I'll put it
on screen yeah and is that is that being
repeated that talking it at a different
city that you can promote
I don't know not yet I'm just sort of
trying it out in Toronto see how it goes
and yeah if the reception is is good
then I can imagine doing it all right
we're the testing ground and maybe I'll
see you there I don't think I'm in town
then otherwise I I don't think I'm in
town it would it would have been great
to shake your hand man
if for whatever reason my other plans
cancel then hey if you find yourself in
New York if you find yourself in New
York at the end of May we're going to do
our first live world Science Festival
since 2019 because of everything you
know we've gone fully digital but we're
going to go live again in the end of May
of 2023 and that's coming up in you know
five six months so it'll be a fun time
in New York and I'm going to do this
program in New York as well
okay I see I see okay yeah well
definitely keep me apprised about the
world Science Festival because as toe
grows sorry the theories of everything
Channel girls maybe there's something I
could do to help promote it and it was
yeah it was a pleasure man
my pleasure too it's good talking to you
the podcast is now concluded thank you
for watching if you haven't subscribed
or clicked on that like button now would
be a great time to do so as each
subscribe and like helps YouTube push
this content to more people also I
recently found out that external links
count plenty toward the algorithm which
means that when you share on Twitter on
Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on toe full-time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you